good evening counselors and welcome to
this February meeting of the council may
remind you all of some domestic
arrangements toilets are situated
outside the meeting room opposite the
stairs cold water is also available in
the breakout area outside the meeting
room if the fire alarm should sound
please leave the meeting room by
following the fire exit signs meet on
the Ipswich Town football training
ground pitch do not pre enter the
building until your tortoise is safe to
do so please switch off all mobile
phones or turn to silent I would like to
remind everyone present that this
meeting will be broadcast live to the
Internet
and will be capable of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items if you make a
representation to the meeting you'll be
deemed by the council to have consented
to being filmed by entering this room
you're also consenting to being filmed
by the council and to the possible use
of those images and sound recordings for
webcasting and all training purposes the
council members of the public in the
press may record film photographs or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the press are not lawfully excluded
finally can members and officers please
ensure that you press the microphone for
speaking and turn off when you finish
can move to the agenda now please
apologies for absence Thank You chair I
have received apologies from councillor
Ayers Karpin dale barrett dawson gold
lindsay plum and norman thank you thank
you
declaration of interest by councillors
are their own declaration
thank you
now we're going to confirm the minutes
of the meeting held on 21st of January
2024 accuracy only are they lean Isuzu
that curacy so can I have a proposal
oh yes council McCraw it's just a
clarification chair on point 200 point 1
[Applause]
that the final sentence read the
overview and scrutiny committee should
review citizens funding Citizens Advice
funding annually the request made by
cabinet Wizards overview and scrutiny to
review the funding of Citizens Advice
not the actual operation of Citizens
Advice which this would imply so I just
like the addition of the word funding
thank you that will be amended yes thank
you
so with that amendment are there any
other issues that we need to review so
with that amendment could I have a
proposer please thank you and can I have
a seconder please councillor Horan thank
you can we take a vote please thank you
that's carried
BC 1933 cuts the mabry now and I'll
repeat could you record that I have not
voted on the minutes I was at this
absent and it does include something
that I could speak on anyway thank you
thank you that would be noted so now BC
1933 announcements from the Chairman and
leader I refer you to paper BC 1933 for
noting Thank You counsel Ward's do you
have anything to report
Thank You chairman yes just a few little
things firstly I'm following recent
commentary in the media I just thought I
care if I a couple of things regarding
the subject of bypasses firstly although
the business case for the Sudbury bypass
is not at present sound due to new ways
of calculating the costs and benefits
weber is still supportive of the project
and we hope it will be revived in the
future which is why it remains one of
the goals in our new corporate plan
conversely whilst the business case for
the exigent route is very strong I
regrettably accept that it would be
impossible to deliver this significant
additional housing needed to pay for the
road middle east suffolk already already
committed to meeting the government's
current housing targets and their new
local plans and are unable to add any
more Suffolk County Council's cabinet
has now formally brought the project to
an end however as I have said in the
press this is a setback for a church and
the whole county and I am sure that all
have to be revisited at some point in
the future hopefully sooner rather than
later you'll have heard last month's
what next for Sudbury Exhibition and
consultation event was very well
attended and we had 569 completed
questionnaires we are now working away
through all the feedback we've received
and we will be discussing what people
have told us with interested parties and
part
first before sharing anything more
widely and finally another plea to sign
up to the mandatory equality and
diversity training please just under
half of members from labor and mid
Suffolk have attended so far and we do
all need to do this so please sign up
Thank You Jenny Thank You councillor
Ward now item five to receive
notification of petitions in accordance
of a council procedural rules Thank You
chair none received item six questions
by the parent by the public in
accordance with council procedure rules
we have received a question from mr.
Marshall unfortunately he is not able to
be here this evening so I will read out
his question and then ask cuts the war
to respond this is the question from mr.
Marshall which I shall read out verbatim
in a recent paper cabinet meeting which
was broadcast on YouTube
it was advised that the proposed terms
to a lease with a hotel operator for the
baldies fight in Sudbury were being
changed from 25 years to 24 years the
chief executive did also propose that
the terms could be changed to 24 years
and 364 days please can you confirm that
the change to the proposed lease terms
has not been done to circumnavigate any
of the effort of community value
implications under the legalism act 2011
which would be a consideration if the
base term were 25 years and not if
closed to circumnavigate what was the
reason for the change councillor Ward
can you respond please
Thank You chairman Bellevue house on the
former swimming pool site have been
listed as an asset of community value
since the 31st of March 2015 the
district council gave notice on an
intention to
dispose of this site originally in 2015
a community bid was received in 2015 but
was unsuccessful when assessed against
the other bids received and this did
contribute towards the delay in bringing
this site forward with a selected party
a hotel operator the 18-month protected
period was triggered again in November
2019 primarily due to the request for
expert expressions of interest in
Bellevue house and the unknown nature as
to whether that interest would be on a
freehold or leasehold basis whilst the
protection is in place against disposal
of both a house and the swimming pool
site a lease of either building for less
than 25 years would not constitute
disposal as defined by the Localism Act
of 2011 therefore should the council
wish to proceed with the lease of the
hotel operator we would be able to do so
on a lease of less than 25 years a final
decision on this has yet to be made also
the design of the hotel scheme has been
an iterative process and several changes
have been made including changing it
from two separate buildings to a single
stacked building to reduce the land's
needed for the scheme the hotel scheme
has been consulted on recently in the
what makes the Sudbury event these
responses are currently been analyzed
and the final review of the whole scheme
will be required before an agreement for
lease is entered into or a planning
application is submitted
this project is good for Sudbury and the
whole district and it has a lot of
support which is why the cabinet voted
for it and full council approved its
financing thank you Thank You Council
award only sure mr. Marshall gets your
response in writing item 7 questions by
councillors in accordance to the council
procedure rules Thank You chair
non-receipt thank you item 8 BC 1934
overview and scrutiny committee report I
would like to invite our McCraw to
introduce his report which is for noting
cuts from accrual
thank you sure you have before you
admittedly afoot somewhat lengthy report
from overview and scrutiny covering
these three meetings held in January I
was a busy month we had to catch up on
our some meetings that had been
postponed
during doing to do two events at the end
of last year I won't go through the
details except to say that the first of
these dealt with the corporate plan
outputs and you can see our resolution
was focused particularly on the point
that the cabinet should be urged to find
a range of methods to engage with all
members to understand the linkage
between the corporate plan that wheel
and these corporate outlets and explain
that where member working groups fitted
into that role the second meeting held
later the same day was an annual
statutory requirement to scrutinize the
Western Suffolk Community Safety
Partnership this was given as usual
thorough examination at the end of it we
concluded that despite the fact that the
work was still continuing not a great
deal had changed since our previous
year's report but we wanted to update
the confidential member toolkit to
provide members with a set of useful and
confidential phone numbers that they
might need might be able to use within
their own wards when the third meeting
was held to look at the general draft
budget that we are looking at now and
the four year outlook and also the draft
revenue housing accounts that was a
draft now you have the actual budget
before you if looking at it it seems
very little changed from those draft
reports so you can see the various items
we raised during our examination we
endorsed the recommendations that the
were contained within the report and
they will be similar to those you have
before you today I'd only like to add
that we noted with satisfaction
both the format in which the reports to
us were presented we felt them to be an
improvement on previous
years much more ease I'm actually more
easily understood and also noted this
satisfaction the new build of 229 homes
because that is something that gives us
a great deal of satisfaction and finally
all I'd like to do is thank the members
of the committee particularly for the
concentrated period of effort that they
put in during January there were some of
us who felt like we spent most of the
months in the endeavour house and I
think councillor Adrian Osborne in
particular with all these various many
tasks involved so I'd like to thank them
and the officers for getting all that
all that and port information to us
happy to take any questions on the
content of the report either during this
meeting or afterwards thank you thank
you cats macaw are there any questions
by councillors it counts the beer thank
you madam chairman yes just a question
to you the the list of phone numbers
confidential what have you will they be
forthcoming to all members because that
sounds a very good idea I think it's
long overdue because if we have
emergencies in our areas or fittings
happen that we need to get some advice
very very quickly it's very difficult if
you've got to try and find out who you
can speak to so I'm very pleased to hear
that thank you
yep the contact toolkit for councillors
was issued last year in October 2018 and
has been available as any sand if you
need a copy of these current one more
than happy to forward that to yes it's
intended to be for all members but it is
specified that some of these numbers are
confidential
because they're not for general purpose
use because they will be dealing with we
are dealing after all with a series of
safeguarding issues and their
confidentiality must be crucial just
waiting for the update but it will be
forthcoming
thank you cuts McCraw any further
questions
thank you we'll move on to our next item
then item 9 bc 1935 general fund budget
20 2021 and four year outlook i would
like to invite councillor Ward to
introduce the paper and to move the
recommendations in the report I'm
pleased to introduce report BC 1935 for
the 2020 to 2021 general fund budget and
four-year outlook the report contains
details of the revenue and capital
budgets and the council's strategic
financial aim it will enable us today to
consider key aspects of the budget and
improve the report it will also enable
us to consider the medium-term financial
position and ensure it is sustainable
the government has confirmed that the
fair funding review business rates
review and business rates reset have
been deferred by 12 months to 2021 to 22
however the financial settlement for
this coming year does give us additional
funding of 265 thousand pounds and
details of this provided in paragraph
four point fourteen of the report we
have a sound financial strategy that
responds effectively to the changing
funding landscape for local government
lists the strategic aims principles and
approach to set out in Section six of
the report in summary we must continue
with our efforts to become
self-sufficient through maximizing our
income streams continue to make
efficiencies and productivity savings
and continue to find new ways of working
the general fund budget setting is just
part of producing a medium-term outlook
for our finances which is both sensible
and sustainable that's why during the
lengthy process we spend a considerable
amount of time working on projecting the
four-year outlook and details of the
funding pressures and savings and income
for the next four years are provided in
paragraphs 8.2 2.18 core to our funding
is need to have a strong council tax
base and so from the perspective of the
four outlook the numbers produce a
compelling case for the need for council
tax increases each year for 2020 to 2021
we will do this at the maximum level
allowed without requiring a referendum
ie five pounds per year or 3.1 percent
for an average banding property reducing
to two percent per annum thereafter
along with a most welcome 2.5 1% growth
in a band equivalent number of
properties for twenty twenty to twenty
to twenty one and one point five percent
per annum thereafter this will ensure
that we can grow our council tax
revenues to help offset the ongoing cost
pressures that we face together these
will provide three hundred and eight
thousand pounds of additional income for
2020 to 2021 the full council deck
details can be found in Appendix C of
your report
now the amended document you've been
given this evening is is an update to
Appendix C and is the result of a late
preset change for Stansted it is only
amended in the numbers vary slightly
we will also be raising long-term
parking charges for the first time since
2012 from two powers to three pounds for
each 24-hour period after the first
three hours free since 2011 to 2012 the
council has achieved cumulative savings
an income of seventeen point four
million pounds through shared services
efficiencies better use of technology
and maximizing commercial opportunities
vindicating the bold decisions that have
been made in that period further savings
in income at two point six million
pounds have already been identified for
next year and beyond the details of
these provided in paragraph eight point
eighteen the general fund budget
requires three hundred and forty four
thousand pounds of the twenty twenty one
to twenty twenty to twenty twenty-one
year homes bonus receipts one point six
million pounds of section 31 and grants
two point two hundred twenty seven
thousand pounds of rural services
delivery grant and two hundred seventy
eight thousand pounds from our earmarked
reserves to achieve a balanced budget it
should be noted that the two hundred
seventy eight thousand pounds from
reserves is less than half the amount we
transferred last year the good news is
that only 33% of the anticipated new
house bonus will be required which will
label us to transfer the surface seven
hundred and eleven thousand pounds to
the transformation fund details of new
homes bonus funding the provided in
paragraphs eight point six to eight
point ten of
report over the next three years the
castle will need to use a hundred
percent of the new homes bonus and a
hundred percent of the section 31 grand
totaling four point eight million pounds
and we'll still have a budget gap of 1
point 1 million pounds at the end of
that period this is described in
paragraphs 8.19 28.2 23 and significant
income or savings or both will be needed
to address this appendix a shows a
breakdown on the council's net cost of
service for this year which is ten point
one six one nine six million pounds and
next year which is reduced to nine point
nine six nine million pounds this is a
decrease of 227,000 pounds for two point
two percent the funding is shown in both
table 10 and Appendix A the full budget
book for 2022 2021 is provided in
appendix D and the proposed fees and
charges schedule is provided in appendix
E the reserves levels are detailed in
paragraph seven point five table 3
whilst we had to use a large amount for
the 2019 to 2020 budget thanks to the
new homes bonus contribution the level
at the end of March 2021 is expected to
improve with a transformation fund a
much healthy nine hundred and ninety
four thousand pounds even with this
improvement the level of revert reserves
excluding sill drops by six percent over
the two years from March 2019 to march
2021 and so this does require close
attention in the future the capital
program is set out in the appendix B and
the plans spent for 2022 2021 is eleven
point four million pounds the main areas
are just under 1 million pounds on
housing grants eight point seven million
pounds investment in tsypko and just
under 1 million pounds on the
continuation of the refurbishment of the
two leisure centers the three major
differences from this time last year are
that we're not expecting to complete the
furthest if Co investment until 2021 to
2022 now the Bellevue capital investment
has been delayed again until 2021 to
2022 and we have yet to dip into the
strategic land and property investment
fund the capital and investment strategy
which you'll hear about later has
further details of the council's
borrowing capacity and the impacts of
the capital
we will be making changes to the ft
property discard the background - this
is explained in paragraphs 11.1 - eleven
point seven we will keep the level of
discount for unoccupied and unfurnished
properties at 25% but reduce the period
from three months to 28 days after which
full council tax is payable the
uninhabited discount the uninhabitable
discount will remain unchanged at 25%
for 12 months if this had been in place
in 2018 we would have raised a further
fifty three thousand pounds in council
tax finally the pay policy statement is
provided in section 12 this is something
we required to do for each financial
year and a section 38 one of the
Localism Act 2011 I'd like to propose
the recommendations in paragraphs 3.1 to
3.5 now I am conscious that most members
will already have had a chance to review
the budget in the very help of briefings
in order to facilitate our understanding
of the key elements and some of you
members of the cabinet and the other
human scrutiny committee will have had a
chance to review at more than once so I
hope you still have some questions and
comments and to assist me in any
questions as usual I have the excellent
finance team here who have to be kind of
graduated on their work on this year's
budget Thank You cancer ward could I
have a seconder please Thank You counsel
I see now we'll open it up to questions
and debate then we would like to ask any
questions
councillor Mayberry thank you madam
chair and first of all two complaints I
removed myself during the last item as I
should not be in the room because I am a
director of a Citizens Advice so that's
why I moved myself and my first question
I have several sucked up up and down my
first is kids council ward confirm that
he said the total surplus transferred to
reserves would be seven hundred and
eleven thousand
because I thought he said 7 3 8 711 is
the surplus of new homes bonus that will
be transferred to the transformation
pond reserve 711 kalsin bay brick did
you have another oh yes Thank You
chairman I have several umm right page
47
um eleven point eight which is reducing
discount period from three months 28
days yes absolutely fine the second half
of that paragraph talks about continuing
a discount for twelve months because
it's uninhabitable I would suggest if
this was reduced we could actually bring
more homes into use cancer ward that is
the aim of reducing the unfurnished and
empty property discount to 28 days the
uninhabitable discount is is remaining
at 12 months simply because its
recognition of the time it takes to get
most properties back into habitable use
that they may need a significant amount
of work doing on them so that's why
we've left that at 12 months cancer may
bring yes I'm going to return on that
because I believe the rulings are if you
don't have a bed and you don't have
water then its class to summon habitable
my suggestion is that some of these
items may possibly be done so that a
property can be kept unfurnished and
uninhabitable so I would have urged a
shorter period the second if I may
page 47 again 11.10 at the bottom I
don't quite understand that does this
mean that if a dwelling has been
unoccupied and unfurnished but then
somebody uses it for six weeks they can
then apply again for it to be classed as
unfurnished I didn't
understand that thank you yes it does
mean that if there's any interim
occupancy period if it lasts for less
than six weeks then it's wrapped up into
the unoccupied and unfurnished period
but six weeks or more than that recess
so that actually means that that would
encourage people to use the property
Thank You page 51 gender pay gap under
12 point 21 which also runs into page 53
in my understanding because we cannot
describe any gender pay gap I cannot see
how we can actually say that there is no
equality what should I say bias so I
would disagree with that and I do
apologize for my cold but I caught this
from a child on public transport but if
you could just explain why gender pay
gap does not affect equality thank you
chief except I'll give an answer but I'm
not sure it's the answer the question
because I'm not sure I understand the
question so I'll give you the app the
answer that can give so that section
talks about the gender pay gap has set
up at the legislation we're required to
report on it the point that the report
is making is technically we are required
to report for Baber and separately in my
case for for mid Suffolk of course you
will know because you have a joint work
force that that creates a nonsense and
so in reality when looking at gender
equality in the and the pay gap the
meaningful way of looking at it is to
look at the total work force and look at
the combined totals because that is your
work force it's not just those who are
technically employed by Baber and just
those who are technically employed by my
mid Suffolk the only way to get a true
feel for it still look at the combined
data but I don't think that answers the
question as I said you like to clarify
oh well um because we do not have detail
so if it's gender pay gap because it
actually says that and it will be
published later that means that there
could possibly be a claim on equality
and that is what I'm querying so I
believe that this is not correct as in
there is no equality bias okay so it's
an agenda for the poll purpose of the
gender pay gap is to establish whether
or not we have any issues in relation to
equality absolutely in terms of claims
in relation to equality that would have
to be in relation to any distinction so
in making a comparison potentially as a
man am i being discriminated against as
it as opposed to how the council treats
a fair comparator not any other woman
but somebody want equal pay for equal
work status so there isn't quite the
same logic if you like between our
connection between a potential equal pay
claim in relation to equality and the
wider gender pay gap you may still have
a gender pay gap but without having an
equality issue in terms of equality of
pay but you still have an equality issue
in terms of the broader sense of the
word the other element for us is
aspirations earnings chief executive is
to make sure that we are narrowing that
gender pay gap wherever we can but we
and we look at that every year not just
because we're obliged to do so but
because we want to do so to look at what
our statistics tell us and what can we
do to try and narrow that gap of course
as you look across the organization that
will vary depending upon the services
that we're providing because if you take
something like waste collection we do
not directly employ our waste collection
staff if we did directly employ our
waste collection staff they tend to be
and I hope I'm not stereotyping but they
tend to be males and that has an impact
on your overall gender equality and your
gender pay gap as a result because you
have a chunk of men at being employed at
a certain rate when looked at and
compared to your staffing I overall so
it needs to be ready in the round it's
very difficult it's not quite your
question again but it's very difficult
to necessarily compare us with another
council because although we all provide
the same statutory functions how we go
about doing that will vary from Council
to council depending on whether you have
a direct workforce or whether you have
an indirect workforce because it's been
outsourced so again if you look at
something like public realm our public
realm is not directly delivered by that
by us it's delivered under contract so
those staff don't count towards our
numbers but are still relevant obviously
in terms of what are we doing overall I
think probably is is trying to splaining
outside of the meeting and with the
gender pay reports that will give you a
much richer picture I certainly look
forward to that it's really interesting
what your comment about waste collectors
minor excellent in my area they are the
best thing ever and I hope somebody will
take that back to the staff and it would
be really good as I've seen in other
areas to have some female waste
collectors because I'm sure they would
be really really good thank you Kelso
may vary any further questions
councillor Hinton thank you thank you
very much and my question is concerning
the perennial problem as I as I see it
with our budget and our accounts and
everything else and that is this
mysterious body called the
formation fund which was supposedly to
transform us from being one council
workforce into two council workforces
and still seems to go on and yet we've
got in if we look at the papers on page
37 it shows a transfer to reserves of
seven hundred and eleven thousand and
somewhere transfer from nowhere
can we some money's going out but he
doesn't say where they're going to so we
have this mysterious pot of money that
he's being added to the whole time but
with no real identity as to what it's
actually used for and it just rather
implies that it's a little bit like the
answer to the member of the public which
didn't actually answer the question as
to whether or not the change of a lease
was to get round a community asset to
order if we've got money in the
transformation fund we can do things
with it without actually asking council
whether it's alright for us to do it
so I would like to know why is the
transformation fund how much is in it
and what it is used for because it
doesn't seem to appear in any of these
figures here cancer ward is that
question for you
try but I'll pass over if I need to and
the transformation fund is as it says on
the tin is for transforming and you
quite rightly pointed out one of the
original purposes but transformation is
an ongoing process it's not something
that is going to be done and then
finished we have to keep transforming to
remain nimble and fit for the purpose of
it for the future and the chief
executive is that already identified a
number of other activities that we we do
need to do and so we have transferred
seven hundred and eleven thousand pounds
as I said from the urines bonus surplus
to the transformation fund reserve now
in addition you will be aware that we
have a climate change task force that is
working on identifying measures to make
us carbon neutral by 2030 this is going
to require funding and so the transfer
we'll be a source of funding for the
climate change mitigation activities
which we will inevitably have to do over
the next few years but I don't know if
Katherine is there anything else you
would like to hire - that I can just add
some clarity in terms of the 22,000
that's going that's planned to go out of
the fund in 2020 21 that is around the
town' visioning work so we're using the
transformation fund to help with that
that visioning work also just in terms
of transparency around the
transformation fund when we're doing the
budget monitoring reports to cabinet on
a quarterly basis there is an appendix
always in that report that shows how
we're spending and there is a table as
well that sets out all the money going
in and out so you get a regular update
on the balances of the transformation
fund thank you thank you
cuts the Hardacre I think you had a
question I'm glad that councillor Ward
mentioned Leone's environmental task
force there's only one sentence in this
entire budget of mentions the
environment and it says words the effect
that managers will consider the
environmental impact of any savings
proposals I'm curious why we're not
concerning the environment impact of
spending council Ward
we're spending in particular and could
you provide some clarification please
interested in the single sentence 19.1
in the bottom of page 53 just says
managers will consider the aberrant
impact of any savings proposals for our
year but there's no other mention of the
environment in this and no mention of
how the environment will be considered
when spending money only when
considering several proposals maybe just
a wording issue but it unfortunate
there's only a single sentence on the
environment I guess it probably could be
worded a bit clearer but as part of our
environmental assessment of any paper or
any proposal that we consider obviously
we'll be looking at the environmental
impacts of whatever we do whether it's
measures we take to to save money or
things we have to spend money on so I
think you can you can really rest
assured council Hardaker that the
environment is something that we are
increasingly putting as a key factor in
decision making at this council and as I
said earlier the climate change task
force will be advising on specific
environmental activities that we're
going to have to take to mitigate the
impacts of climate change and meet our
carbon neutral aspirations cancer hinton
thank you madam chairman if I can just
come back on what the councillor Ward
says what we're proposing to do on
climate change and other aspects in the
future surely should be budget items and
not just something that disappears into
a mysterious pot called the
transformation fund we're talking here
on page 87 of an estimated balance on
the 31st of March of three hundred and
six thousand use of reserves
now what reserves are those are those
reserve
of the council or are they part of the
transformation fund 20 2002 reserves is
at reserves of the council or is it the
transformation fund 711 thousand we have
all these different terms being used
which rather hide the fact that there is
a great big pot of money slopping about
the place but nobody seems to have any
control over except cabinet and as I
remember when we first introduced the
concept of cabinet to this council we
gave them a 50,000 pound limit on what
they could actually authorize so where
is the money what's it going to be used
for and when we actually gonna be told
what it's gonna be used for so that we
can approve it beforehand if necessary
that's the ward yep the point about a
reserve is unless it's a specific
earmark reserve it's there for four
useless that will be identified in the
future at the moment until we've had the
report back from the climate change task
force we don't have specific items
specific projects that we will need to
spend that money on cut some lvc I don't
know if you've got an update on on the
climate change task force and and where
we are with that perhaps it might be
quite useful to provide a summary to
Castle Hinton thank you
Thank You councillor warden madam
chairman and councillor Hinton climate
change encompasses a multitude of issues
it's not just a case of planting trees
it's not just a case of having electric
charging points and the task force is
currently working in collating all the
information we've vari we've been held
up because we've tasked groundworks to
produce some data and the data gathering
has been problematical for them and they
will probably they should be delivering
to us later in march by which time we
end of March we're putting together the
actual report for Council and we should
be delivering to Council sometime in
April then just when we can tell us how
much things will cost but until then we
can't because how long is it Lisa string
I think he cut some well Vaizey
cuts the Hinton did you want to yeah on
that on that point what is groundworks
expertise and what data are they
actually collecting their mops you're
actually going to tell us council of AZ
I can just finish up what do you think
it probably won't tell us it's the fact
that he Stanga has been slowly dipping
into the sea since the last ice age
which I'm sure it won't be mentioned
council phasing trouble is I'm having a
senior moment here I'm a daughter how to
trace the email on my laptop to be able
to tell you but ground works I worked
with groundhogs 20 years ago up in
Manchester to implement the waste oil
regulations when they were brought in
around about 97 they do environmental
impact assessments across the country
and they will be bringing to us to the
work force information and data on
Carbon Reduction Thank You
customer-facing Mary Gore everyone back
now to the paper that were meant to be
discussing have any other councillor got
anything they'd like to ask regarding
this paper councillor Horan yeah it's
just a quick run chairman thank you
some get was touched on before 11.7 page
47 it's say the council is liable to pay
council tax on their own unfurnished and
finished properties I just wonder is
there an audit trail to do that I would
ask that now wouldn't
or is this just tallied up at the end of
the financial year and we do swapsies
just however does that work we pay
ourselves in other words I would presume
or transferred from one part of Bay but
to another and I'm just interested to
know how that is actually done and also
how sharp are we on billing housing
associations for unfurnished unfinished
properties empty properties in other
words I'll have to get back you on that
I don't have the answers to your
questions counsel Horan at the moment so
if you'll bear with me I'll I'll find
out yeah okay
Thank You councillor Busby I believe you
had a question I've only read this thing
about four times so excuse me if I've
missed something but if you've a
compared to 135 Appendix B of the joint
investment strategy its if we look at
the Bellevue Sudbury line sounds like a
railway forecast at the end of this
year's 2282 point seven five million
then it jumps to six point five three
million implying that there's a
expenditure of about two and a half
million in one year and 3.8 million in
the next which is fine if we go back to
page 86 custom ASCII are you on a still
on paper the general fund budget is
because that's page 86
[Applause]
if you go back to page 86 which then
shows investment and commercial delivery
Bellevue capital program for the next
four years it's got the 2.5 million in
it doesn't seem to have the 3.8 million
in for the next year so I'm going to
explain that Kathryn are you going to
take this one oh that looks like an
error in appendix B unless I think I can
assist it's in the column that's being
brought forward from the current
financial year so it's in the first
left-hand column in column B for 3.8
million so it's already in it in the
approved capital program but it will be
moved for from the current year into the
year that it's needed so it will be
carried forward into 2021
have you further questioning on that um
can't suppose beep I mean I didn't
understand the answer I don't believe
the answers quite correct I can't see
with the 3.8 million expenditure is it
comes in according to the schedule that
we've got in the joint investment
strategy it comes in after we spend the
2.5 million not before it so I can
understand where you hunt where the 3.8
million appears in the general fund
budget officers are you able to give
some further clarification please yep I
think there is an error in the budget
book if I can refer you to page 56 there
is an extra column in there
so you think in that table you have got
the 3.8 million shown is being brought
forward so you've got the 6.6 million
they're in total so yeah acknowledge
there is an error in that budget book
page but we'll update that before we
publish it online does that now make it
clear it's just the order that you've
put them in on page 135 appendix B for
joint investment strategy it clearly
shows that the expenditure will be 2.5
million first and then 3.8 million next
how according to your figures that we
seem to be bringing forward to 3.8
million expenditure with are you
reversing the way that we're planning on
funding it or financing you think the
capsule and investment strategy appendix
is how we now expect the profiling to
work what you're seeing in the budget
report is that some of that money is
already in an approved capital program
so it's there already and we will need
to move it forward into the years that
it needs to happen
but since the capital investment
strategy is how we're currently thinking
that the payments will profile so it's
just a slight difference between what's
already been approved and how we think
we will actually spend it at a time when
we will spend it
but happy thank you any further
questions on this paper I see no further
questions
Oh cut can't say possibly can we create
the recommendations separately please
335 rather than on mess we have to take
a recorded vote and if we do it that way
we'll have to take a vote a recorded
vote on each item separately is that
acceptable I'm monitoring officer Thank
You chairman and the council could
decide to take each one individually
however there does need to be a recorded
vote by roll call for each of those
sections of the recommendation because
remember that they is a whole
recommendation just divided into
sections if there was a particular
element that members would like to draw
out I would suggest that that might be a
way forward rather than taking each one
individually but of course the the will
of the council will be adhered to cancel
a crore
thank you ma'am sure um in looking at a
budget it strikes me that it either all
hangs together or it all doesn't hang
together and I believe it does hang
together I don't think you can start
cherry-picking individual
recommendations of the totality of the
budget here it is it's a budget if there
is an aspect of it that somebody finds
they cannot agree with they have the
simple option which is of course to vote
against that budget person as a safe
having scrutinized it and closely and
as has been pointed out seeing the draft
budget figures many times and yes I can
see where there are issues with the
interpretation of figures I mean looking
at the joint investment strategy and
comparing it to figures in the budget
frankly doesn't seem to me to be
entirely fair since the documents serve
different purposes but effectively we're
looking at the budget the general fund
budget and that's it one one one go one
vote thank you cuts mcore council Busby
K suave we've got the five record
separate recommendations if it's one
budget look I'll put it straight 3.2 I
cannot vote for it but I won't vote
against it
I want to abstain and I want it recorded
that I was damned don't you wish to
abstain from the whole process so we're
going to take the vote on block in
accordance with council procedure rule
19.3 immediately after any vote has
taken at a budget decision meeting of
the council the names of the councillors
who cast a vote for the decision or
against the decision or who abstained
from voting shall be recorded in the
minutes of that meeting and I asked Joan
Robertson to conduct this or take a
recorded vote for and against and any
abstentions
are we taking 3.1 to 3.5 as one decision
yes so we're not allowed to sort of pick
and choose think aright which bits we
don't think a right correct so in other
words we've got to say no to all of it
rather than one bit of it that's correct
doesn't seem very democratic but still
Thank You chair I should call out to a
name and if you could answer fork
against or abstain Thank You councillor
Aarthi or pants the beer councillor
Busby council Creswell counselor Davis
or counselor Fraser
that's a Granger Howard that's a Grandin
four counts a Hardacre councillor Hinton
counts the Holt counts the Horan counts
two Jameson handsome faz counts the
Mabry count some cruel council McCarran
hats the Newman cancer none councillor
Adrian Osborn counts to Jan Orsborn
cancel it Owen counts the Parker counts
the wards
[Music]
yep carry the vote is carried for will
now move on to item 10 BC
1936 housing revenue account budget 20
2021 and longer-term outlook I would
like to invite councillor Ward to
introduce paper BC 1936 and to move the
recommendations in the report I'm
pleased trying to use support BC 1936
for the 2022 2021 housing revenue
account budget and long-term outlook he
covers both the HRA revenue account and
the capital program we have a sound 30
year business plan which has resulted in
favorable positions both revenue and
capital for 2020 to 2021 we have been
helped by the ending of the annual 1%
rent reduction imposed by the welfare
reform and work act 2016 the act now
allows rents to be increased by CPI
which is currently set 1.7 percent plus
1 percent for five years from 2020 to
2021 the remaining 25 years of the
business plan are based on an annual
rent increase of CPI only the full
30-year business plans is attached of
Appendix B a fundamental review of the
housing service has been undertaken
during 2019 to 2020 to identify savings
efficiencies and income generation
opportunities to achieve a sustainable
business plan into the future and the
scope of this review is provided in
Section seven point one of the report we
are continuing with our aspiration to
increase our housing stock new homes of
all types of providers with new homes
burners and council tax but additional
council housing also delivers rental
income and wider financial and social
benefits the table in sections 10.1 of
the report sets out the HRA budget for
2020 to 21 based on a 2.7 percent
rent increase and highlights the
movement from the past year's budget
a surplus position of 334,000 powers
forecasts which is a significant
improvement on the 2019 to 2020 position
which was the deficit of 193 thousand
pounds this has been achieved by
reducing both revenue and capital
budgets as you can see in table 10.1 and
we are proposing to transfer this
surplus to the HRA reserves key adverse
movements highlighted in the budget are
a reduction in income of 187 thousand
powers primarily due to 2020 to 2021
being a 52-week year whereas last year
was 53 weeks and also there have been
delays in new bills there's an increase
of 189 thousand pounds and general
management costs due to staff costs and
the transfer of the ICT budget to the
HRA there's also been a small increase
in repairs and maintenance and also for
property services a set against these
favorable workmate there are fair
favorable variances most notably a
reduction in the revenue contribution to
capital of 1.0 4 7 million pounds due to
the revised capital program in addition
to the rent increase we are proposing to
increase sheltered housing charges by 2
pounds per week to ensure recovery of
the actual cost it is proposed that
utility charges are kept at the same
level as the current year Garrosh rents
will remain at the current level and we
will continue to look for alternative
uses for unviable garage sites we
continue to look for income and savings
opportunities and next year we'll see a
focus on all contracts for 50 thousand
pounds to review the terms of each of
these and to identify savings
opportunities as well as the decision on
the long-term future of building
services by a joint venture with
flagship housing a review of the HRA
business firm will also be undertaken
income increases or savings continue to
be reflected in the budget and will be
monitored during the year finally I'd
like to note that right to buy sales
were lower than those projected in the
business plan in 2018 to 2019 babe
result 15 properties against an original
projection of 27 sales the reinvestment
limited 30% of right to buy sales income
will be an increasing problem as I build
and acquisitions program progresses
Baber amid suffered responded to the
government's recent consultation on
right to buy a detailed breakdown of all
the HR 8 earmark reserves both revenue
capital forecast as at the 31st of march
2021 can be found in Appendix C and
shows an improvement over the year of
nearly 1.9 million pounds paragraph 6.2
of the report shows the predicted
movement and there is revenue reserves
over the next 30 years and it shows a
slight reduction from twelve point nine
to twelve point six million pounds and
paragraph six point three serves as a
debt repayment profile for the next
thirty years with all debt being repaid
by twenty forty nine to twenty fifty
paragraphs 11.1 to eleven point four
summarized the capital investment
program for the next four years and then
pendeks a provides more detail section
six point four gives a graphical view of
the expenditure I'm working with I seen
each identified development sites we are
aiming to build a further hundred fifty
six affordable homes and twenty-three
for shared ownership over the period
twenty twenty to twenty twenty-three we
are anticipating a cumulative capital
program budget of just under fifty one
point two million pounds which includes
twenty six point nine million pounds for
the new bills and acquisitions to be
financed from a number of sources as
shown in paragraph 11 point 2 and the
appendix including eleven point seven
million pounds of borrowing no strategic
priority reserves will be used to
finance this program I'd like to propose
the recommendations in paragraph three
point one to three point nine over your
report and to assist me in any questions
I do have a finance team and also Gavin
Fisk here as well thank you Thank You
counsel Ward could I have a second
please Katsaros cool thank you
we'll open it now up to questions and
debate would anyone like to that's the
beer and thank you madam chairman
just Ryu to the leader and the cabinet
member for Harrison can I be assured
that you will ask your team to look at
the possibility of the garages that are
not being used
or possibly becoming derelict whether
they could be usefully used by demolish
them if necessary and those space has
been made available for parking in some
of our hard-pressed areas on a Estates
thank you cuts Rosberg thank you madam
chairman yeah there's a a review of
garages currently being undertaken and
in that report it clearly states that
one of the they will be looking at other
options apart from the possibility of
housing but also to create additional
parking spaces as well we need to bear
in mind that some of these garage sites
are mixed tenure so we need to bear that
in mind but know that is one option
that's been looking at council then
thank you cut some Ebury hmm thank you
madam chairman
um can I just ask if the two pounds per
week increase the sheltered housing
service is that in addition to the
increase in rent please that's all yes
it is thank you
can I just ask also why the garage rates
are not being increased because to my in
my opinion those who are really
vulnerable and require sheltered
accommodation seem to be paying more and
I understand that there has been a
subsidy are being paid about being
charged a lot more where some of that
could have been offset with the rent or
garages there are a couple points the
the shelter housing increase is to
offset the actual costs which have been
increasing for the shelter housing
services but in terms of the garage
prints many of them are garages are
actually tied to Castle house tendencies
anywhere not the less separately but
with with the voids the vacancies we
have in garages we do realize that we do
need to provide some form of incentive
to to take up garage rinse and so
consequently we
felt that it wouldn't have been prudent
to increase the rents at this stage and
in any event the potential increase in
income would be very limited from from
doing that thank you um in my opinion
garages are usually used for storage and
I would have said that increasing the
garage rents would have helped I
understand that some of these garage
blocks some of them are empty some of
them are used and I'm going to say
mainly for storage and if there was an
increase perhaps that would have freed
those up so the sites could possibly
have been used for more housing
counselor Osborn thank you madam
chairman that's the whole reason we're
doing an evaluation of all our garage
sites to establish quite interesting
that counsel Osborn is answering when
done counselor waters actually put this
paper forward because it's always been
Council Osborn in the past and so we
seem to be having two people answer
thank you
if you cast your man back to last year I
did present the HRA budget as well as
the general fund budget counselor I was
born as answering the questions that are
specifically relating to the housing
service because she's the cabinet member
for housing if you had a financial
question on the HRA budget I would
answer it
thank you cancer ward any further
questions
yes cuts the Hardacre I noticed on page
102 and the the debt overview chart it
says the shows different types of debt
held by the hey cherry over the next 30
years however this is based on a reduced
level of new-build and acquisitions
after the first two years because that
chart goes up to what appears to be this
green ceiling does that mean that we've
effectively binding future ourselves in
the future if we chose did
actually want to build nor can you
repeat the last part of that so just
asking if it says here that it's
assuming that we're going to reduce the
amount of new builds after first two
years and then the debt goes up to this
line does that mean that we will be
unable to build anymore if we want to
because I think we should be building
more gavin can you can you pick up on
Thank You chair
um just answer the question in relation
to the Green Line it's a Prudential
borrowing limit that we set following
the removal of the former debt cap that
line can shift subject to the ambition
of the council to build more houses the
program is based on the current program
in the next two to three years in terms
of delivery of new homes but yes I'd
expect that table over the 30-year life
of the HRA to continue to shift in terms
of new debt new boring to support new
housing delivered in in the district
council McCraw I just wonder if it's
worth at this point bringing up the fact
that the scrutiny asked a specific
question on the intention of building
new housing I referred earlier to the
229 houses proposed in the current
program and we specifically asked if
that was going to be the end of it was
there an intention of continuing such
program of new building and the answer
received was yes there was just that
intention but obviously we can't tell
what will happen in the future but yes
this is definitely something that we
were told would be going forward and I
think that might answer councilor hard
acres intentions I think he cuts them
across any further questions
councillor Hinton
Thank You mr. chairman page 106 it talks
about the capital investment program for
the HRA and talks about new building
acquisitions twenty six point nine
million and then a bit further down as
councillor Ward mentioned talking about
building a hundred fifty six affordable
homes and 23 shared ownership homes
nowhere in any of these charts does he
show where the income from right to buy
has actually gone and what is the figure
for this current year that we have built
into the business plan for right to buy
losses if you like to the housing stock
that's the Wold are you wishing to
answer this question
I can't find it at the moment - yes
Govan governor you able to answer this
please okay if I can if I haven't aired
a question correctly table on eleven
point two does explain the level of
right to buy receipts in terms of
financing the number of right Tobias has
been declining over recent years and we
will continually revise the ARA business
plan according to those projections is
very prudent to ensure that we don't
project lower numbers of writer buys
then actually I received
thank you ma'am so in other words it's
hidden within for other items to make
sure we can't actually pin down what how
much of actually is have you got any
further questions
counselor Mabry would it be possible for
all members to have the actual figure
from right by receipts please
got sup possible to provide that
information I'm happy to go away outside
of the meeting and and look at providing
you some figures on on the precise
enough amount of rock by receipts that
would be fine thank you
any further questions councillors
no more questions
fine well this is again a recorded vote
so we'll take the vote and block like
last time and so John Robinson walls
hurry up this vote for us Thank You
chair
so same again councilors if you could
say for against or abstain counselor
Aarthi counselor beer counselor Busby
counsel Creswell counselor Davis or
counts the Fraser
that's the Granger Howard that's the
Grandin for that's a hard acre that's
the Hinton counts to Holt councillor
Horan councillor Jamison counts amel
Vaizey
counselor Mabry that's them accrual
counts the McLaren counts of Newman
counts for none counts for Adrian Osborn
counselor Janet was born counselor Owen
counselor Parker and councillor Ward
thank you so I think that's quite clear
that was a unanimous vote for will now
move on to item 11 BC 1937 joint capital
investment and treasury management
strategy 2022
21 I would like to invite councillor
Ward to introduce paper BC 1937 and to
move the recommendations in the report
councillor Ward Thank You chairman this
is the third and last one I'm pleased
sir excuse for 4pc 1937 the joint
capital investment and treasury
management strategies for 2022 2021 this
is the second year that we have separate
capital investment and treasure
strategy statements and prudential
indicators following the new guidance
issued by both sit fur and the MH CLG
this report is part of the council's
legal obligation under Local Government
Act 2003 to have regards both the city
sit for code and the ministry for
housing communities and local
governments guidance MH the audience if
are aware that most local authorities
are taking a more commercial approach in
order to bridge the gap they face as a
result of diluting funding and
government although they have both
stated that they do not seek to
prescribe precisely how castles invest
they do have concerns that some councils
are taking increasing commercial risks
using borrowed money as a result this
report provides a more extensive
strategy so that more of the risks that
the codes and guidance highlight are
apparent about our apparent to members
appendix a is the capital strategy it
summarises the capital expenditure and
financing requirements of the full
capital program both general fund and
HRA the details of which are in the
budget reports but you've just discussed
this sets our capital expenditure and
capital investment decisions and the
associated risks and the rewards along
with how risk is managed for future
financial sustainability capital
expenditure for the next four years has
shown a table Rock at one at paragraph
2.3 the financing is shown in table 2
paragraph 2.11 these show that the total
capital expenditure plan for 2020 to
2021 is thirty two point eight nine
million pounds and most of the general
fund expenditure will be funded from
borrowing Appendix A also includes
prudential indicators which demonstrate
that the investment plans the council
has had are affordable prudent and
sustainable and decisions are made
according to good practice tables one
four six eight and nine
illustrate the affordability and impact
of capital expenditure decisions and set
up both councils overall capital and
treasury framework borrowing measured
against two benchmarks the capital
financing requirement and liability is
shown in table six and seven Babis
capital financing requirement is
expected to increase by twenty one point
three four million pounds to 170
seven point seven seven million pounds
into two thousand twenty twenty two
twenty to twenty one and the outstanding
debt to increase by fifteen point two
five million pounds two hundred thirty
eight point two 1 million pounds statute
e guidance says that debt should remain
below the CFR is set in the short term I
just need to draw your attention to a
couple of minor Corrections on page 130
paragraph seven point two the paving
number should read four point four four
percent and the mid suffered nine point
nine three percent to align with the
table below moving on to the investment
strategy Appendix B
he tells those expenditure items in the
capital program that specifically
relates as assets bought or owned by the
council's to generate a return or for
regeneration or development of the local
area in this context investments means
non treasury management activities which
are described separately in Appendix C
there are two types of these investments
service provision whether councils lend
to or buy shares in organizations to
provide a service and for-profit
commercial investments which generate a
return such as the council's own
company's citko and gateway 14 but also
are directly owned property assets it
explains how each investment contributes
to the council's priorities and their
security liquidity and risk both
councils are continuing to develop their
property and commercial portfolios
either by purchasing them directly or
through the council's investment
companies Appendix C sets out the
council's borrowing requirement in the
treasury management strategy and
borrowing and treasury management
investment strategies are included as
well it also includes a list of approved
investment counterparties and limits
table one at paragraph three point three
is the key table here showing the
breakdown of the capital financing
requirement over the next four years
both councils have an increasing CFR due
to the capital program and investments
appendix D contains the treasury
management indicators which we use to
measure and manage the council's
exposure to treasury management risks
Appendix C provides the economic update
and interest rate forecasts and they're
following the Bank of England decision
to hold industry
0.75% in November Arleen closed our
treasury advices and now forecasting
that it is likely to remain at this
level for the foreseeable future
appendix F describes the current
investment and debt portfolio
it shows the position at the 30th of
November 2019 the external borrowing at
that date for Baylor was a hundred and
two point five four million pounds of
which ninety six point five four million
pounds was public where its loan board
borrowing as six million short term
borrowing our investments of that date
were thirteen point eight seven million
pounds which can lose the ççla funding
circle UBS and Schroeder's we have
continued the policy of withdrawing
funds from funding circle as loans drop
out and nor have we invested any new
money there appendix G provides the
treasury management policy statement
which underpins the strategy and sets
out both councils regard to the
monitoring of risk and performance the
primary objective of both councils
towards investments is security of
capital followed by liquidity and then
return the pendeks H is the minimum
revenue provision statement which shows
where we put aside the resources to pay
debt in later years appendix I lists the
institutions meeting highly credit
ratings criteria finally appendix G is a
glossary of terms I'd like to propose
the recommendations in paragraph three
point one to three point seven of your
report thank you Jim
thank you cast award could I have a
seconder please counselor Hulk
we can now open up to questions and
debate has a capsule Mabry madam
chairman and it is mentioned paper it is
separately mentioned baby growth
limited and do those who are directors
here have to declare and leave the room
no it's a local non-pecuniary impressed
I've been told any other questions
yes cancer regard to the campuses in
Hadley that will agree to the sound and
the new company SAP last year do we have
any idea when that worth is likely to
start though on those on the council
offices Thank You councillor Jensen cuts
award uh late spring hopefully and and
do we know they would that be when that
will be what we completely data is D
targets don't have an estimated
completion date or the build-out profile
for the Baybrook Court slain site I
don't know Emily do you have any idea of
that
okay we're still working on the
build-out profile for these schemes and
looking at how we how we phase the
release of those units in an appropriate
fashion so there will be more
information that comes forward in in due
course any further questions
if there are no further questions we'll
move to a vote on the recommendations in
the report this it will not be a
recorded vote it'll be a show of hands
so those in favor yes we're doing it all
together
those in favor can you show your hands
please
uh are there any against and any
abstentions I see two abstentions thank
you the voters carried will now move on
to item 12 recommendations and reports
from cabinet committees JC 1910 hearty
report on cloture a management 2019 20 I
would like to invite councillor Horan to
introduce the report and to move the
recommendations in report
councillor Harun thank you thank you
madam chairman
a new voice this should have come before
you I think at your last meeting but due
to other things going on it's a bit late
there's a certain amount of overlap with
what John has has just read out and in
the previous paper this is the joint
treasury management report covering the
position for the first six months of the
financial year 19 to 20 it provides
details of the performance effects of
decisions taken during that period and
confirms compliance with the council's
treasury management policy the report
explains in more detail the factors
affecting the strategy and activities
including the regulatory framework
economic conditions interest rate and
liquidity risks interest rates during
the year continued at very low levels
and the Bank of England rate remains at
three quarters of one percent even
though leaving the EU was delayed until
thirty first twenty a key concern is the
limited transitionary period following
exit date which will maintain and create
additional uncertainty over the next
years adding to that the ongoing dispute
about the imposition of tariffs between
the US and China continues to contribute
to a slowdown in the global economy
during nineteen and into 20 more
specifically for our council's banking
avoc activities undertaken were within
the daily bank account limits each
council has reduced its short-term debt
Baber by just under a million nine eight
nine K and mid suffered by two point six
seven million the canceled investments
activities included average returns can
be found at Appendix C of the report for
you and that's on page 187 chairman both
councils made other investments of two
point million each and a high yield and
strategic pour fund namely the investing
diversified income fund which I think
plays about 3% code I'm sure that will
be clarified in a minute investment by
both councils in funding circle has
reduced as Ana allocated funds have been
reclaimed and existing loans repaid both
councils are compliant chairman with the
upper limits for the interest rate
exposure the investment activity
undertaken for the half-year was done so
in priority order of security and
liquidity over yield as bright as
prescribed in our strategy and as a
paragraph that appendix a12 which page
179 Chairman I think that indicates
there seriously we take these matters I
would say when I took on this role I get
expected to be a bit mundane and boring
but not proved to be the case and the
team are absolutely superb John Snell
isn't here tonight I don't think he gets
so excited about these figures it's
beginning it's beginning to rub off me
I'm getting extreme
we worried and I must pay tribute to
Katherine Melissa answer who the driving
force behind all this that's very very
important I'm very impressed that our
money and other people's never seems to
stand still even if it's only here for a
week
it's invested somewhere quite a
reasonable rate and when I say even if
it's not on many of its money we clicked
for the place the County Council it
never sits in the bank idle it's working
for us all the time and that's why you
know that they're not actually gambling
and taking punts at night it goes
through a broker and it is all regulated
but it is very good and that's what
makes it interesting and the money hours
and every else's is in really good hands
and I am quite enjoying this role if
there are questions Melissa and
Katherine are here to answer they're
probably going to be far too hard for me
as yet but between us we will endeavour
thank you Thank You counselor and I
think you're getting us all excited
about the figures - may I have a
seconder please Thank You councillor
Ward will now open this up to questions
and debate councillor Hinton thank you
ma'am chairman one said I can get
excited about it but one of the things
that concerns me if you like about it
was that the the report has been
presented to us is a little historical
and doesn't sort of look too much into
the veneer future we've seen in recent
day is what's happened to those stock
markets around the world in terms of the
coronavirus and the effects it's having
on the financial markets we're hearing
about the amount of trade from China
that is just sitting there doing nothing
now that's obviously gonna have an
impact on what happens around the world
has this been taken into account when
looking at our treasury management
exception because it's opportune to have
quite considerable impact on the world
economy and ours in particular because
Phoenix though as we know is one of the
in Chinese imports culture Horan's this
one for Catherine sale or would you like
to take it myself not too much of the
details this is something we will be
dealing with obviously it is worrying
times it's what we're here for and we
will handle it competently but with
other things that have gone on last year
it I agree it's not good news and we
should all be concerned there are no
facts and figures as yet but we will be
watching him okay any further questions
or comments so there are no further
questions or comments we'll take a vote
on the recommendations in the report all
those in favor of the recommendations in
report that's carried thank you we'll
now move on to item 13 BC 1938 proposed
changes to council meeting dates 2020 21
I would like to invite councillor Ward
to introduce paper BC 1938 and to move
the recommendation in the report Thank
You councillor Ward thank you this
reporter just highlights a few changes
to scheduled council meeting dates
throughout the year and into next year
just to streamline and make fluent the
way that we work and operate in terms of
having council meetings
there are only two or three that have
changed but you'll see that we're going
to have meetings essentially every two
months throughout the year but with one
or two exceptions there'll be a meeting
that's put in obviously for the budget
in in February and
if if there's any need for any further
meetings that that need to be slotted in
if an agenda does require that then
obviously we will but this is based
around that the likely workload and the
agenda profile throughout the year so
consequently I propose the
recommendation that we changed the the
meeting schedule here and make the minor
changes that are highlighted in the
table you've got it three point part of
the report thank you can I have a
seconder can't sabir can I invite you to
questions and debate any questions or
debate please cut Slatington Thank You
chairman well we seem to be opt opting
for a reduction in the number of
meetings for council which is the one
time when ordinary councilors can get
involved in what is happening at cabinet
and everywhere else within the council
and we've already seen the problems that
effectively happened with though
overview and scrutiny because of the
delay or the the freezing of council
business in the autumn because of the
impact that we were going to have on the
national elections which struck me as
being a little bit strange because they
don't freeze what's happening in
Parliament when we have our local
council elections or County Council
elections so and they're more likely to
have an impact on our results and then
we are on them that's beside the point
we were told to do it we were good
little boys and girls and did it but
this is a reduction in the number of
meetings of full council and our ability
to tell the public and to cross-examine
on behalf of the public and I don't
think that it is compliant with our open
and transparent clauses within our
Constitution and with the
corporate strategies Thank You counsel
Hinton caps award it's only a reduction
of two and it's cognizant of the fact
that we have canceled council meetings
in the past and this will make sure that
we've got a regular set of meetings
throughout the year but when you said
it's the only time that members get to
to scrutinize business that's not
actually true you you're all very
welcome to attend cabinet meetings and
also meetings of the joint overview
scrutiny and joint audit and standards
committees cancer Makram thank you sure
I must confess I was a little bit taken
aback at the same way as John Ward as
Sir John Henson was I
I can't support this not because I don't
see the practicalities of it there may
well be very good practical reasons I
don't think it sends a very good message
we have eight meetings a year and and
yes there have been occasions where we
need you know the lack of items to put
on the agenda we've had cancellations of
those meetings fine let that be so if
that is the case but I would have said
canceling in advance before we even know
what might or might not be even with
we're anticipating so reducing the
number of opportunities for ourselves
for members of the public to ask
questions of counsel and cabinet I think
is probably a retrograde step I couldn't
support it I think it's a democratic
deficit and I will never support one of
those I appreciate this might cause some
inconveniences there may well be
meetings that could be canceled amongst
the council's agenda some discussion
took place to deny group about
possibilities of certain briefings that
were fundamentally just repetitions of
the same thing but I don't believe that
what we are voted but what we are
elected to do what people think is the
primary function of AG answerer jointed
the main council meetings should just be
casually got rid of as I say if these
meetings do need to be changed if we can
stick to the current chair
and then we have to cancel fine but
there has to be a reason given why that
is the case the other thing is that if
we just cancel now we lose the bookings
for the rooms and we all know how
difficult it is to get bookings and
coming up with a meeting at the last
minute and then trying to get the
council-chamber
might not always be possible so I won't
be supporting that's made my experience
elsewhere and anyway I won't be
supporting this and I think members
should think very hard before agreeing
to something that has that effect
counsel Davis sorry counselor what what
did you what to reply yeah I did mention
earlier that members have the
opportunity to come to cabinet meetings
and ask questions and also the other
committee meetings and it is the fact
that democracy doesn't just happen
in this chamber there are the the out
the other committees that through which
members can come and can ask questions
and construed nice the work that goes on
Davis okay cut some all I would say to
the chair the leader of the council is
that these are our showpieces or should
be budget being a very good example
these are the moments where people
expect to be following us and they don't
really generally follow committee
meetings or cabinet meetings thank you
that's a Davis thank you and I've got
two questions but I just want to make a
point first of all obviously we do live
stream now so members of the public can
watches on here and same with the
cabinets and the planning committee so
they can use that and as you can see by
the matter of the public here tonight to
look at the budget probably they're all
at home watching it on TV my two
questions are this in the reports it
says that they there's no financial
implications and B there's no
environmental implications but surely
both of those it will save money if we
didn't have these meetings and also
environmentally and we are we have made
a pledge to be more environmental
friendly
it would save however many people who
turn up
today some are already here all day but
those that haven't they've made that
journey so I think in the report
possibly lacks the detail in both the
finance and the environmental impacts
Thank You Kelsey Davis any other
questions
can siharan I must admit I'm concerned
about this I think I would rather be in
a position where you have one booked and
cancel if you don't need it and have to
scrub around to find one also I think we
have set processes here don't we and
things tend to go to committee maybe to
cabinet and then come to full Council
and I do think it concentrates the mind
possibly of officers and counselors
we've got a deadline coming up we need
to get it to that full council meeting
if it's not there I'm not saying that
everybody goes to sleep for a month but
I think it does take away the urgency of
what we used to and I think that's my
main point I'm uneasy about it I would
rather put one in and then take it out
if we don't need it then not have it
there I think while it's there it's
something to aim at and we are in danger
of losing it thank you
that's the polka thank you
yeah I've got some sympathy actually
with with with what some of my
colleagues are saying but I don't know
if I've missed something but the detail
is very scant why what what is the
benefit of of going these meetings or
the number of meetings that's the Lord
well it's just purely based on the
anticipated workload given what we've
experienced over the past a couple of
years and to be able to smooth that out
over the year sorry castle
I'm still a little bit confused while we
anticipate your workload going down or
anticipating the word oak going up
workload staying the same and giving the
fact that we have council meetings in
the past because of lack of sufficient
items for the agenda and this is to
ensure that we will have full and
regular meetings every two months with
one or two extras filled in in between
got some more busy and thank you madam
chairman I support it because from an
environmental perspective look at the
amount of paper around here that would
be reduced the number of car journeys be
reduced I think we should seriously
consider it we made a pledge we have to
be the ones to show the way to reduce
waste thank you
Thank You councillor Mayberry Thank You
chairman um my question Lee is probably
to the monitoring officer if the council
meetings a move to one every two months
and they happen to fall on month for my
experience a workday does this mean that
the six months rule will not come into
effect
Thank You chairman and the six-month
rule in terms of having to attend a
council meeting at least once every six
months will always stand it's in
legislation unless the councilor has
been granted a dispensation from
attending by the council and there are
set reasons why that might be acceptable
and while I've got the floor if I'm a
chairman and if I can offer some
reassurance for the council these
programs for this program of dates
hasn't just been arrived at willy-nilly
what we've done is we've considered the
sheduled business of the council so
items that regularly come up here on
year and we've also anticipated our
forward program of work and this the
months that we've chosen to dereyes
these meetings make the most logical
sense in terms of when those items of
business come forward and there is
always the opportunity to convene
additional meetings as and when required
but I do think that this program will
adequately cover the council's business
over the next municipal year
particularly given that this council has
recently reviewed many of its key major
strategies which is some of the workload
that has come through this council
meeting in the past year thank you thank
you
cuts the Criswell Mike my concern is
some this meeting obviously is an
evening time mr. Ward said go to other
meetings but quite a lot of them
happened to be in the daytime so I think
you want nearly and full attendance of
all your councillors on a full meeting
and I think cutting down the means might
not be a good thing Thank You counselor
counselor Busby
yeah Thank You chair I mean if we're
going to cancel some of these meeting or
any meetings I'll scrap the joint
cabinet meetings or the cabinet briefing
then we won't have to deal with these
things all times which is what we're
doing at the moment it appears it's very
good it's very easy for the cabinet to
be on top of things because we meet very
regularly probably directly but if you
were a regular counselor you're not
necessarily aware of what's going on and
we did a constitutional review not long
ago which was the outcome was to tip the
balance back in towards council meetings
rather than cabinet making decisions and
this is to be going against that I think
the cabinet meetings are importantly
that they say they were crucial I think
that what we could do is to look at the
kind of items that we deal with in the
cabin meetings I think there should be
more open debate before decisions are
made perhaps so it's a combination of a
debate and the councilmen it doesn't
have to be just here to make to
rubber-stamp a decision which is what
this lot was but whether we could be
make much better use of having all
counselors here to get their views from
across the district on issues that are
affecting us Thank You councillor Busby
cut some accrual yeah I think that's a
very good point I mean I just like to
add that committees meeting them to bear
in times planning meets approximately
every two weeks or can do although
occasionally there isn't that not enough
on their agenda in which case they
cancel but it's understood that it will
meet every two weeks and the program is
drawn up accordingly okay that's the
standard thing audit might meet what
three times four times a year once a
quarter yeah okay and I do come from a
meeting today where we meet once every
six months
the area of scrutiny scrutiny is meeting
every month and as I pointed out earlier
I'm not saying you know for us I'm
saying that like members of the cabinet
members of scrutiny get a much better
idea of what's going on in Council and
we are talking about all members of the
council those members as has been
pointed out can't attend in the day
times those members who can only be here
at evenings and and I do still think
that the Democratic deficit so I'd ask
the leader of the council to reconsider
this motion and perhaps just to think
about whether those baits and whether in
a different approach might be better for
the good of the council cuts the ward
and just to clarify the cabinet meets
ultimately during the day and you're an
evening so we're not solely at the
daytime committee and in terms of the
the the ability or the subject matter
that comes before Council as opposed to
comes before cabinet that doesn't matter
for the Constitution and there's certain
things that are reserved for cabinet and
other matters that are reserved for
council and we were not in the position
to to change that just just by a matter
of decree is something that has to be
agreed as a constitutional change but I
think if we didn't make this change now
as the monitoring officer has said this
is based on an understanding of the work
schedule and work profile throughout the
year we'll end up where we are now and
we'll be canceling meetings and we'll
still be at the the same number of
meetings and same frequency that we're
proposing in this revised schedule II
it's just a matter of regular rising
what effectively happens as a matter of
course
that's a hinton interesting while
councillor Ward has said how can you
regularize something when it's on a
different day of the week every single
time you have a meeting we're talking
about the next scheduled meeting page
six of your papers its 20th of April
Mundy normally we have council meetings
on a Tuesday but we didn't
because Suffolk County Council cabinet
threw us out so they could discuss their
budget so we have to move it to
Wednesday
if we're gonna regularize something
let's regularize it and just point on
the environmental issue if all the
councillors have to come in to cabinet
so they can keep up to date with what's
going on that's gonna increase the
number of car journeys not reducing
cancer ward we're on YouTube council
Mayberry and if I can come back from sit
until that one but if it's on YouTube
then can is it possible then for members
to come in into Skype and ask questions
that way because at the moment it isn't
the cabinet is only for those people who
are present can ask questions Council I
think we can look into that there's some
technically it should be feasible it's
just a matter of the practicalities of
arranging that but I'd be open to open
to that as a an option I'm glad to be
fuse that's yes Thank You chairman just
not what the last word but according to
what some other people said I think I
might say what price democracy and I'm
amazed how many people do watch us live
or recorded online I friends in Boxford
who know what I say the following
morning because they sit up in bed and
listen to we almost have a groupie
following but if there's no meeting I
feel there will be a deficit in
democracy in this I really do feel that
and you can make all the arguments about
bits of paper if we're not seen to do
the job properly and get in a muddle
then we'll be burning more
and paper to get ourselves out of it so
let's stay as we are and then if we have
no business well we can always declare
it and cancel the meeting and I think my
point I made before we concentrate the
mind on a shader is a very valid one as
well chairman thank you I will shut up
now councillor Davis yeah if it's of
help a couple of us councillors did a
livestream with one of the well a few of
the schools coming in together and they
emailed their questions and comments
live so I think whether it's Skype or
whether it's an email facility through
YouTube we've got the technology you
know we should be using it and you're
right we don't yeah we've got laptops
from odd gov yes we've got some late
papers all that paper be printed out for
example so that there are ways of
improving it but councils have to engage
you have to move with the times
Kelsey Busby and the June meeting that
suggested to be removed could I suggest
that we have a climate change debate on
that so that the could council over
there could bring us up to date with the
progress to date I mean this is such an
important topic for us I think it's
about be about time for us then to
engage Council of AZ did you want to
come back on there
no pressure at all Thank You counselor
and we would you two meet on the 10th of
March that data's be postponed
it has been put back later because as I
said earlier to councillor Vinton we're
waiting for the what's known as a
baseline report from ground works and
once we have that data in then we can
write our report and present it to
Council and we know in April we intend
to do it in April yes
so unless somebody else knows of any
differences that is one we're looking to
present it you can certainly that as it
gets lost you know you know an agenda
which is I've got 15 items on it and by
the time we get around to discussing it
will passed it deserves it deserves to
be a full council discussion it might be
it doesn't have to be a council making a
good opportunity to do it I thoroughly
agree with you
it covers energy it covers vehicles it
covers trees verges waste collection
waste disposal so the number of subjects
and the ramifications of this climate
change report is huge it's really big so
I would welcome a full debate on it
and I look forward to it when it comes
when we get the report members really
suggest that we talk about the content
of any future meetings outside this
meeting because we're really here to
discuss how many meetings and whether
we're going to cancel or whatever future
meetings rather than discussing the
content of such meetings so if we could
keep please keep it to the advantages or
disadvantages of the proposed timetable
please thank you
any further comments councillor Aarthi
just one that's only just occurred to me
really and it's a procedural issue
because I see that this was agreed the
original timetable was agreed on the
24th of September 2019 if this is a
council decision we can't actually
change that until March the 24th coming
six the six month rule a monitoring
officer will tell us Thank You chairman
and it's always good to have a
procedural question to answer
you're not rescinding a decision you're
not going overturning a decision that
you've previously made you're making an
alteration to a schedule of dates
that's previously being agreed so that
would be allowed without breaching the
six-month rule
thank you chairman accepting what the
monitoring officer has said but surely
if we are reducing the number of
meetings we are overturning part of that
decision so we're picking and choosing
with words and technicalities over
something that really is a fundamental
part of democracy
and I've given my advice on the the
procedural point I would suggest that
the council consider now moving to a
vote on the matter however what I would
say is if you vote against this new
proposed schedule you'll revert to what
was previously agreed there are some
minor alterations of dates that are in
months where you previously had council
meetings so you might want to consider
those I don't know whether an amendment
might be appropriate in that in that
regard those could always be changed as
they had been previously because of need
and I don't think there's any difference
so I still think about for or against is
just the same I mean you know that their
points are unchanged if you need to
change the dates of the agenda as it was
you can do so you never had that didn't
never didn't have that option so I think
we're ready now to move to a vote can we
take a vote for the proposed new
schedule those for the proposed new
schedule please show hands
those against any abstentions right it's
carrot madam chairman I'm a point of
order can we have the figures because to
the public watching at home there's no
idea yet could you tell us the number of
votes 1310 I've been told I didn't vote
so um we'll move on now to item 14
counselor appointments I'd like to
invite counsel to introduce this item
Thank You chair this is just one very
small change into the planning committee
the conservative members of the planning
committee I'd like to replace counselor
Zack Norman with counselor Mary McLaren
and are there any more changes in any
other committees thank you can we take a
vote on this please
well sorry I need a seconder cuts the
beer thank you yes cut sir Hinton can we
assume that this change is due to the
fact that that Norman can't get here
during working hours and therefore the
increasing or the rejection of meetings
is gonna make things difficult it's
actually irrelevant that's not part of
what we're here to discuss today thank
you um so we'll now take a vote all
those in favor please
that's carried thank you so where we've
reached the end of today's meeting thank
you very much everyone for some lively
debate
I'd like to your to Nick that the next
meeting as someone observed earlier is
Monday the 20th of April at 5:30 p.m. so
thank you very much for likely evening
this evening and good night now 7:24 I
close the meeting